the delta variant is a mutated variant
of the original coronavirus and was
first identified in india in december
2020 leading to major outbreaks in the
country it then spread rapidly and is
now reported in over a hundred countries
across the world the delta variant also
known as b16172
can spread more easily according to
health officials
the strain has mutations on the spike
protein that make it easier for it to
infect human cells that means people may
be more contagious if they contract the
virus and more easily spread it to
others it is now the dominant strain in
many parts of the world including the uk
and the united states according to
estimates the delta variant is between
50 and 60 more contagious as previous
versions of the virus researchers are
still trying to understand the mutations
that account for this but preliminary
studies suggest that changes in its
spike protein make it more efficient at
both grabbing onto receptors and getting
into your cells
the delta variant also seems to lead to
higher viral loads than other variants
viral load is a measure of how much
virus is in your nose and throat one
study found that at the beginning of
their infection people with the delta
variant had viral loads a thousand times
greater than those people infected with
the original version of the virus people
with delta variant also reach their peak
viral load faster according to this
study which has not yet gone through
peer review the delta variant poses a
threat to us all not just those
countries with large numbers of
unvaccinated people this is because
unlike the previous alpha variant which
first emerged in the uk
the first doses of the vaccines do not
offer enough protection against it
meaning people are at risk in the
interval period between the two doses
according to public health england a
study they published in may a single
dose of either astrazeneca or pfizer's
vaccine only reduces a person's risk of
developing covid19 symptoms caused by
the delta variant by 33
a second dose of the astrozenica vaccine
boosts protection against delta to 60
while two doses of pfizer protect up to
88
the delta plus variant also known as
b161721
is considered a sub variant of the delta
version it has a mutation that allows
the virus to better attack lung cells
and potentially escape vaccines
first identified in india delta plus has
now been found in the us uk and nearly a
dozen of other countries
india has labelled it a varied concern
but the who haven't
the key to protection is to get fully
vaccinated it is only by taking both
doses of the vaccine can you protect
yourself against serious illness from
the delta variants
you